your purpose is to shut down comedy
because you find it offensive because
you're a second-rate comedian who made a
documentary that sucks you talentless
South Asian so this is the story gonna
move on today is the Simpsons and Hank
Azaria now is apologizing for a poo so
question should stereotypes be allowed
in comedy as we see in the Simpsons and
what if anything in comedy we talked
about how the left is ruining comedy but
what do you think is off-limits do you
think that comedy also in 2018 is better
off or worse off than where you were
first allowed in a comedy club or of age
you know where I'll end up I am
absolutely just terrified at the current
state of comedy for proof of such let's
look to today's main story Huffington
Post is now rejoicing over the fact that
Hank Azaria might step aside for the
voice of a poo - of course make room for
progress so he was on a late-night
comedy show at Colbert show the arbiter
of all things funny and you know that
it's funny because of the Apollo he is
number one stop on apology tour - the
politically correct left let's see what
he had to say Hank Azaria a poo and it
sparked a lot of conversation about what
should be done with the character going
forward which is not so easy to answer
and I've tried to express this before
you know the idea that anybody was with
young or old pastor present was bullied
or teased based on the character of a
poo it just really makes me sad it was
certainly not my intention I wanted to
spread laughter and joy with this
character and the idea that it's you
know brought pain and suffering in any
way that it was used to marginalize
people it's upsetting
Jenny genuinely okay first off maybe
everyone wasn't an absolute pansy back
then maybe Indian kids back then had
plenty of any kids you into my school
one of them dressed up as a poo for
Halloween
they weren't offended this crowd maybe
just that now everyone is offended by
all the actual things and by the way how
many how many fat kids were referred to
as Homer Simpson or Peter Griffin it's
not exclusive just to an Indian
character give any idea how terrible
actual bullying is almost lushy quick
you really think that that's destroying
some kids self-esteem you really think
that a poo destroyed the self-esteem of
Indian girl so she became a someone
stripping her way through college
I watched Google you once I know how
bullying yes exactly I wash it they made
fun of they they made fun of the gay kid
she singing jochen's you want to know
what in real life that kid never gets
made fun of ever you just say you're gay
sing show tunes down the hallway you
have a Hall Pass
and by the way a bill for those who
don't it's a totally patriotic
entrepreneurial immigrant who loves
United not a bad stereotype it's not a
bad series on business and a lot of
times multiple he owns his own business
which by the way native 1/8 America FC
I'm saying Native Americans let me say
Mis now they going to say South Asians
they don't want to say India South
Indians the United States make more than
the average American because they come
in yes that is that was actually built
not just through being doctors or
lawyers but bodegas franchises small
businesses very very industrious people
Appu is not a negative stereotype it's
because there's a funny accent which by
the way the Indian accent is kind of
funny also gets a notification Bell if
you're subscribed on YouTube because
that doesn't mean anything anymore if
you want to be in the loop for when our
videos come next let's go to the next
clip for this hilarious conversation on
comedy I think that if anybody came away
from that segment feeling that they
should lighten up or take a joke better
or grow a thicker skin or does something
sad like like we'd like we've heard what
you said and we were not going to
respond
yeah that's certainly not the way I feel
about it
and that's definitely not the message
that I want to want to send it okay yeah
we never want a comedy show to be the
one to tell people to lighten up if they
feel like they want we want them to
lighten up or did all have a thicker
skin that's why you exist that's the
sole purpose of your program how are you
supposed to make you feel a little
uncomfortable yes and you're supposed to
be able to address subjects that you
can't otherwise what comedy has there's
always a bit of pain people understand
every single joke has a little if you
take the most corny Christian Camille
ette me take the oldest joke of all time
why does it say why did the chicken
cross the road why to get to the other
side the joke is you the pain is how
high your stupid the whole comedy comes
from a little bit of pain and that's
okay that's not what he that wasn't the
message he wanted his message now is
that comedians need to apologize even
though it's twenty-five years later
because things can retroactively ly be
considered offensive that's the message
that's being sent right now is we don't
want to tell we don't want to have a
comedy show tell people to lighten up or
develop a
your skin I really want ya know we
should we should have all the things
retro actively be apologized for
everyone who likes Blazing Saddles and
wrote a positive review on Metacritic in
2002 we need them to bring that down
yeah uh Brautigan our show said this
morning it's not enough that you don't
couldn't make it now you that's what's
enjoy you're not supposed to enjoy it
now and if you enjoy it you need to
analyze what's wrong with you as to why
you enjoy it and then get put on
psychotropic medication we wouldn't even
be able to watch anything at that point
because something is going to be
offensive to somebody at some point
that's exactly where all of its gone hey
speaking of what's defense let's go
let's continue to the interview let's
continue on the let me make this clear
continue with the comedy interview with
a late-night comedy show and as I say my
eyes have been opened and I think the
most important thing is we have to
listen to South Asian people Indian
people in this country talk about
there's an Indian it's I think what they
feel and and and how they think about
about this character what their American
experience of it has been yeah that's
what's most important as a comedian you
don't have to listen to you're not a
psychologist you're a comedian it's just
crazy to me this is this is the
boilerplate release it's we I think
what's most important is to listen and
if anyone's feelings word while you're
on your apology or okay you can
apologize for Godzilla mm please
everything retro actively offensive net
what would okay what about bugs bunny
when he was a female bunny its Pepe
LePew now rape culture if people shut it
off and you lose your audience that's
that's comedy that's the voice speaking
back that's how you're listening how
many that I used to do with comedians
but like The Simpsons or comedy shows
and in South Park and Family Guy that's
what they did how many times did we hear
when we were growing up if Christians
were upset or wanted a boycott something
they would say well if you don't like it
shut it off change a channel South Park
people said all the time it's all part
if you don't like it shut it off no
that's it that used to be a message if
you don't like it shut it off this but
this is right now and by the way there
are millions of people who still like
and watch The Simpsons this is actually
giving a door to any and all hecklers
it's giving just as much power to the
heckler as it is to the comedian and the
audience now picture this in a comedy
club a comedian tells a joke a joke
about our dozen of who does an
impression tells a joke the entire
audience is laughing but one person like
Oh or the people who make these
documentaries are the people who demand
apologies for all things offensive in
comedy one heckler speaks up and says
boo that's offensive
what hank azaria is saying is that
person's opinion which is a small
minority is just as valid as not only
the opinion of the audience who've paid
to be there or who've tuned in who've
paid with their time but as valid as the
person who created the art in the first
place people don't understand they're
retro actively giving authority to
hecklers and empowering them it used to
be someone spoke I'm offended you say
well shut up and get out of the club
when you make fun of their mother
generally implying that she would have
hi mouths I'm kind of a [ __ ] invite
them on stage exactly now it's saying
let's listen to the heckler
by the way this is microphone for people
who don't know this all stems from a
documentary from a self-professed
comedian and Indian American South Asian
American I don't know how they call it
now a self-professed comedian telling
other comedians what comedy should be
because that's how you know it's funny
this documentary
my name is Hari Kondabolu I've had a
great career filled with laughter
critical acclaim I should be completely
happy but there's still one man who
haunts me I'm poo Nahasapeemapetilon a
white guy doing an impression of a white
guy making fun of my father there are
accents that by their nature to white
Americans sound funny period it's funny
because it's racist
does that poo count as a minstrel since
it's brown paint a white guy's voice
actually no it's funny because it's
foreign to us and generally just like my
mom's french-canadian accent everyone
here laughs she doesn't thing that you
hate her she doesn't thing that you're
racist it's just funny because she adds
an S where there is not one needed and
one where there isn't say hey guys I'm
going to go down to a dude the store
grocery and buy some shrimps chuckle
Thank You Francine be sure to wash your
hands with tea yeah behind you be sure
to wash it if you are sick take the oil
of Teebs do you mean leave oil oils
mother now I'm gonna give you that the
plural when you say Mike give me a hard
time
thank you where's my mom goes it's Nicks
no mom there's no floral on there but
you think it's funny because there's no
it's
it's funny because it's foreign mr.
Indian documentary field kind of like
your people do in India let's see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a lot of pelvic thrusting but
we're gonna be mad because of a cartoon
character with an accent just so you
know not everyone in The Cleveland Show
voiced by a black guy either not only
India let's get all cultures do this
they all tend to laugh or make fun of
other cultures or at least observe the
differences because that's what makes
comedy you look at the differences of
people and you see what you see what
bonds us together
grated they don't do it that well in
Mexico look what they do here it's
pretty silly Mexicans Mexicans racial
slur for the Mexicans who just put a guy
in blackface and said he was covered in
tar
we may be monetized will they be what
this is what so just - yes when will
they be I wonder that wonderful Mexican
what if that blackface Mexican who they
covered and seemingly chia pudding that
was the worst blackface ever I wonder if
he's woke he is now he's is if you want
to pay for that you wants to be on a
Mexican sitcom you ever seen Mexicans
sell cars
it's just tits it's by the pop scene by
ourselves you ever seen these commercial
sex cells another guy sells in Latin
American country here's what's so crazy
to me is this is the state of comedy and
that's why I asked you what do you think
with the state of comedy in 2018 it can
no longer be fun or when you see Amy
Schumer now with the recent it's not
listen it's not because she's fat and
unattractive it's because she demands
that we praise her for being fat and
unattractive and she talks about how
comfortable she is and how Comedy needs
to have comedy sometimes doesn't need to
have a purpose and here's the thing when
comedy does have a purpose it now
according to left needs to be the right
purpose or it's not a lot in comedy a
lot of comedy that we do here has a
purpose and it has a more meaningful
purpose than telling women that their
stretch marks are awesome or telling
people they need to apologize for an
Indian accent it is a purpose actually
espousing freedom and freedom of speech
and making sure that people who actually
exercise these rights aren't imprisoned
aren't find like you see with count dank
EULA or a friend Mike Ward was before
Human Rights Tribunal in Canada
we're dealing with our comedy that's the
purpose to our comedy your purpose is to
shut down comedy because you find it
offensive because you're a second-rate
comedian who made a documentary that
sucks you talentless South
asian-american which doesn't make that
much sense as I say it out loud I feel
bad about it now compare that that's
comedy in 2018 you want to tell me that
that's more fun than what comedy used to
be late-night used to be maka manga
nonso was hurt from be new boombots oh
two bullets in the head Thursday
but I tell you I'm a Jew and you're an
Italian and here we have what this is a
great Irishman this is America yes well
it used to be
Hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing
you roll you're here this is the end of
it so we don't care because you already
watched it but if you really didn't like
it and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because that lets the overlords at
YouTube know that you know what you're
alright